[Music]
you've probably heard of the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle from quantum
mechanics that the more you know about a
particles position the less certain you
can be of its momentum and vice-versa
Michael here is for you to come away
from this video feeling like this is
utterly reasonable it'll take some time
but I think you'll agree that digging
deep is well worth it you see the
uncertainty principle is actually one
specific example of a much more general
trade-off that shows up in a lot of
everyday totally non quantum
circumstances involving waves the plan
here is to see what this means in the
context of sound waves which should feel
reasonable and then Doppler radar which
should again feel reasonable and a
little bit closer to the quantum case
and then for particles which if you're
willing to accept one or two premises of
quantum mechanics hopefully feels just
as reasonable as the first two the core
idea here has to do with the interplay
between frequency and duration and I bet
you already have an intuitive idea of
this principle before we even get into
the math or the quantum if you were to
pull up behind a car at a red light and
your turn signals were flashing together
for a few seconds you might kind of
think that they have the same frequency
but at that point for all you know they
could fall out of sync as more time
passes revealing that they actually had
different frequencies so an observation
over a short period of time gave you low
confidence over what their frequencies
are but if you were to set at that red
light for a full minute and the signals
continued to click in sync you would be
a lot more confident that the
frequencies are actually the same
so that certainty about the frequency
information required an observation
spread out over time and this trade-off
right here between how short your
observation can be and how confident you
can feel about the frequency is an
example of the general uncertainty
principle similarly think of a musical
note the shorter it lasts in time the
less certain you can be about what its
exact frequency is in the extreme I
could ask you what the pitch of a clap
or a shock wave is and even someone with
perfect pitch would be unable to answer
and on the flip side a more definite
frequency requires a longer duration
signal or rather than talking about
definiteness or certainty it would be
little more accurate here to say that
the short signal correlates highly with
a wider range of frequency and at the
signal correlating strongly with only a
narrow range of frequencies must last
for a longer time here that's the kind
of phrase that's made a little bit
clearer when we bring in the actual math
so let's turn now to talking about the
Fourier transform which is the relevant
construct for analyzing frequencies the
last video I put out was a visual
intuition for this transform and yes it
probably would be helpful if you've seen
it but I'm gonna go ahead and give a
quick recap here just to remind
ourselves of how it went let's say you
have a signal and it plays five beats
per second over the course of two
seconds the Fourier transform gives a
way to view any signal not in terms of
the intensity at each point in time but
instead in terms of the strength of
various frequencies within it the main
idea was to take this signal and to kind
of wind it around a circle as in imagine
some rotating vector whose length is
determined by the height of the graph at
each point in time right now this little
vector is rotating at 0.3 cycles per
second that's the frequency with which
were winding the graph around the circle
and for most frequencies the signal is
kind of just averaged out over the
circle this was the fun part of last
video don't you think just seeing the
different patterns that come up as you
wind a pure cosine around a circle like
this but the key point is what happens
when that winding frequency matches the
signal frequency in this case five
cycles per second as our little vector
is rotating around and it draws all of
the peaks line up on one side and all of
the valleys on another side so the whole
weight of the graph is kind of
off-center so to speak the idea behind
the Fourier transform is that if you
follow the center of mass of the
wound-up graph with frequency F the
position of that center of mass encodes
the strength of that frequency in the
original signal the distance between
that center of mass and the origin
captures the strength of that frequency
and this is something I didn't really
talk about in the main video but the
angle of that center of mass
the horizontal corresponds to the phase
of the given frequency now one way to
think of this whole winding mechanism is
that it's a way to measure how well your
signal correlates with a given pure
frequency so remember when we say the
Fourier transform were referring to this
new function whose input is that winding
frequency and whose output is the center
of mass thought of as a complex number
or more technically it's a certain
multiple of that center of mass but
whatever the overall shape remains the
same and the graph that I'm drawing is
just going to be the x-coordinate of
that center of mass the real part of its
output if you wanted you could also plot
the distance between the center of mass
and the origin and maybe that better
conveys how strongly each possible
frequency correlates with the signal the
downside is that you lose some of the
nice linearity properties that I talked
about last video anyway point is this
spike you're looking at here above the
winding frequency of five is the Fourier
transforms way of telling us that the
dominant frequency of the signal is five
beats per second and equally importantly
the fact that it's a little bit spread
out around that five is an indication
that pure sine waves near five beats per
second also correlate pretty well with
the signal and that last idea is key for
the uncertainty principle what I want
you to do is think about how this spread
changes as the signal persists longer or
shorter over time you've already seen
this at an intuitive level all we're
doing right now is just illustrating it
in the language of Fourier transforms if
the signal persists over a long period
of time then when the winding frequency
is even slightly different from five the
signal goes on long enough to wrap
itself around the circle and balance out
so looking at the Fourier plot over here
that corresponds to a super sharp
drop-off in the magnitude of the
transform as your frequency shifts away
from that five beats per second
on the other hand if your signal was
really localized to a short period of
time then as you adjust the frequency
away from five beats per second the
signal doesn't really have as much time
to balance itself out around the circle
you have to change the winding frequency
to be meaningfully different from five
before that signal starts to balance out
again over on the frequency plot that
corresponds to a much broader peak
around the five beats per second and
that's the uncertainty principle just
phrased a little bit more mathematically
a signal concentrated in time must have
a spread out fourier transform meaning a
correlates with a wide range of
frequencies and a signal with a
concentrated fourier transform has to be
spread out in time and one other place
where this comes up in a really tangible
way is Doppler radar so with radar the
idea is you send out some radio wave
pulse and the pulse might reflect off of
objects and the time that it takes for
this echo signal to return to you lets
you deduce how far away those objects
are and you can actually take this one
step further and make deductions about
the velocities of those objects using
the Doppler effect think about sending
out a pulse with some frequency if this
gets reflected off an object moving
towards you then the beats of that wave
get kind of smooshed together so the
echo you hear back is going to be a
slightly higher frequency Fourier
transforms give a neat way to view this
the Fourier transform of your original
signal tells you the frequencies that go
into it and for simplicity let's think
of that as being dominated by a single
pure frequency though as you know if
it's a short pulse that means that our
Fourier transform has to be spread out a
little bit and now think about the
Doppler shifted echo by coming back at a
higher frequency it means that the
Fourier transform will just look like a
similar plot shifted up a bit moreover
if you look at the size of that shift
you can deduce how quickly the object
was moving by the way there is an
important technical point that I'm
choosing to gloss over here and I've
outlined it a little more in the video
description
what follows is meant to be a distilled
if somewhat oversimplified description
of the Fourier trade-off in this setup
the salient fact is that time and
frequency of that echo signal correspond
roughly to the position and the velocity
of the object being measure which is
what makes this example much more
closely analogous to the quantum
mechanical Heisenberg uncertainty
principle they see there is a very real
way in which a radar operator faces a
dilemma where the more certain you can
be about the positions of things the
less certain you are about their
velocities here imagine sending out a
pulse that persists over a long period
of time then that means the echo from
some object is also spread out over time
and on its own that might not seem like
an issue but in practice there's all
sorts of different objects in the field
so these echoes are all gonna start to
get overlapped with each other
combine that with other noise and
imperfections and this can make the
locations of multiple objects extremely
ambiguous instead a more precise
understanding of how far away all these
things are would require having a very
quick little pulse confined to a small
amount of time but think about the
frequency representations of such a
short echo as you saw with the sound
example the Fourier transform of a quick
pulse is necessarily more spread out so
for many objects with various velocities
that would mean that the Doppler shifted
echoes despite having been nicely
separated in time are more likely to
overlap in frequency space so since what
you're looking at is the sum of all of
these it can be really ambiguous how you
break it down if you wanted a nice clean
sharp view of the velocities you would
need to have an echo that only occupies
a very small amount of frequency space
but for a signal to be concentrated in
frequency space it necessarily has to be
spread out in time this is the Fourier
trade-off you cannot have crisp
delineation for both and this brings us
to the quantum case do you know who else
spend some time immersed in the
pragmatic world of radio wave
transmissions
ayoung otherwise philosophically
inclined history major in World War one
France Louis debris and this was a
strangely fitting post given his
predispositions to philosophizing about
the nature of waves because
after the war as debris switched from
the humanities to physics in his 1924
PhD thesis he proposed that all matter
has wave-like properties and more than
that he concluded that the momentum of
any moving particle is going to be
proportional to the spatial frequency of
that wave how many times that wave
cycles per unit distance okay now that's
the kind of phrase that can easily fly
into one year and out the other because
as soon as you say matter is a wave it's
easier to just throw up your hands and
say physics is just weird
but really think about this even if
you're willing to grant that particles
behave like waves in some way whatever
that means
why on earth should the momentum of
those particles the thing we classically
think of as mass times velocity have
anything to do with the spatial
frequency of that wave now being more of
a math than a physics guy I asked a
number of people with deeper backgrounds
in physics about helpful intuitions here
and one thing that became clear is that
there is a surprising variety of
viewpoints now personally one thing I
found to be interesting was just going
back to the source and seeing how to Bro
frame things in his seminal paper on the
topic you see there is a sense in which
it's not all that different from the
Doppler effect where relative movement
corresponds to shifts in frequency it
has a slightly different flavor since
we're not talking about frequency over
time instead we're talking about
frequency over space and special
relativity is going to come into play
but I still think it's an interesting
analogy in his thesis dubrow lays out
what is in his own words a crude
comparison for the kind of wave
phenomenon he has in mind imagine many
weights hanging from Springs with all of
these weights oscillating up and down in
sync and with most of the mass
concentrated towards a single point the
energy of these oscillating weights is
meant to be a metaphor for the energy of
a particle specifically the e equals
mc-squared style energy residing in its
mass and bra emphasized how the
conception he had in mind involves the
particle being dispersed across all of
space the whole premise he was exploring
here is that the energy of a particle
might have
do with something that oscillates over
time since this was known to be the case
for photons and these oscillating
weights are just meant to be a metaphor
for whatever that something might be
with Einstein's relatively new theory of
relativity in mind he pointed out that
if you view this whole set up while
moving relative to it all of the weights
are going to appear to fall out of phase
that's not obvious and I'm certainly
exaggerating the effect in this
animation it has to do with a core fact
from special relativity that what you
consider to be simultaneous events in
one reference frame may not be
simultaneous in a different reference
frame so even though from one point of
view you might see two of these weights
as reaching their peaks and their
valleys at the same instant from a
different moving point of view those
events might actually be happening at
different times understanding this more
fully requires some knowledge of special
relativity so we'll all just have to
wait for Henry Rice's series on that
topic to come out right here our only
goal is to get an inkling for why
momentum that thing we usually think of
as mass times velocity should have
anything to do with spatial frequency
and the basic line of reasoning here is
if mass is the same as energy via e
equals mc-squared and if that energy was
carried as some kind of oscillating
phenomenon similar to how it is for
photons then this sort of relativistic
Doppler effect means changes to how that
mass moves corresponds to changes in the
spatial frequency so what does our
general Fourier trade-off tell us in
this case well if a particle is
described as a little wave packet over
space then the Fourier transform where
we're thinking of this as a function
over space not over time tells us how
much various pure frequencies correspond
with this top wave
so if the momentum is the spatial
frequency up to a constant multiple the
momentum is also a kind of wave namely
some multiple of the Fourier transform
of the original wave so if that original
wave was very concentrated around a
single point as we have seen multiple
times now that means that its Fourier
transform must necessarily be more
spread out and hence the wave describing
its momentum must be more spread out and
vice versa notice unlike the Doppler
radar case where the ambiguity arose
because waves were being used to measure
an object with a definite distance and
speed what we're saying here is that the
particle is the wave so the spread out
over space and over momentum is not some
artifact of imperfect measurement
techniques it's a spread fundamental to
what the particle is analogous to how a
musical note being spread out over time
is fundamental to what it even means to
be a musical note one pet peeve I have
in mainstream references to quantum is
that they often treat Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle as some
fundamental example of things being
unknowable in the quantum realm as if it
is a core nugget of the universe's
indeterminacy but really it's just a
trade-off between how concentrated a
wave and it's frequency representation
can be applied to the premise that
matter is some kind of wave and hence
spread out all of the stuff about
randomness and unknowability is still
there but it comes one level deeper in
the way that these waves have come to be
interpreted you see when you measure
these particles say trying to detect if
it's in a given region whether or not
you find it there appears to be
probabilistic where the probability of
finding it is proportional to the
strength of the wave in that region so
when one of these waves is concentrated
near a point what that actually means is
that we have a higher probability of
finding it near that point that we are
more certain of its location and just to
beat this drum one more time since that
concentration implies a more spread-out
Fourier transform then the wave
describing its momentum would also be
more spread out so you wouldn't be able
to find a narrow
change of momentum that the particle has
a high probability of occupying I quite
like how if you look at the german word
for this principle it might be more
directly translated as the unsharp ness
relation which I think more faithfully
captures the Fourier trade-off at play
here without imposing on questions of no
ability when I think of the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle what makes it
fascinating is not so much that it's a
statement about randomness I mean yes
that randomness is very
thought-provoking and contentious and
just plain weird but to me equally
fascinating is that underpinning
Heisenberg's conclusion is that position
and momentum have the same relationship
as sound and frequency as if a particles
momentum is somehow the sheet music
describing how it moves through space
[Music]
you